à nîmes dans le gard karine trap est en
grève de la faim depuis le 1er mars pour
récupérer la garde de ses enfants samuel
et noah déjà très faible elle a perdu
plus de 10 kilos depuis 2017 et de vifs
conflits avec le père du cadet samuel
elle est engluée dans une bataille
judiciaire
les enfants ont tout d'abord été confiée
chacun à leur père respectif à des
centaines de kilomètres de leur mère le
père de noah étant incapable de s'en
occuper
l'enfant aujourd'hui âgé de 11 ans a été
placé en foyer en 2018
depuis quatre ans alors qu'elles
contestent les décisions de justice la
jeune femme de 36 ans voit surgir des
obstacles toujours plus grand pour voir
ses enfants dans le dossier de karine
trappe en 2017
le rapport d'un psychiatre décrit un
conflit parental intense et des
fragilités psychologiques
depuis la jeune femme a apporté mende
preuve de sa stabilité professionnelle
et sentimentale
mais elle reste privée de ses fils le
mot qui me vient toujours à l'esprit
c'est surréaliste
aujourd'hui encore là elle n'aime pas
réaliser les étapes qu'a pu avoir c'est
vraiment des années de procédure à n'en
plus finir les fois où vous vous dites
ça va se débloquer quoiqu'en
objectivement le routier mal chez son
père voulait le garder on vous refuse on
met en foyer ça paraît sur ali sont ici
pas se débloquer à ce moment là en
septembre dernier avec un rapport un peu
plus favorable des services fournis de
même une mesure judiciaire
d'investigation éducative donc c'est
vraiment une enquête un rapport
favorable on se dit ça y est c'est le
début de la fin non mais on vous en
remet une couche
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour trouver
que la grève de la faim tous les jours
car il se rend devant le tribunal de
nîmes pour protester accompagné de
nombreux soutiens
lors de notre visite son avocate s'est
emporté contre l'engrenage dans lequel
sa cliente est prise
plus elle voit qu'elle n'est pas
entendue plus elle crie sa douleur
les décisions se sont enchaînés dans un
pseudo intérêts supérieurs de l'enfance
on sent qu'on a gratté davantage en
france plus de 300 mineurs bénéficier au
moins d'une mesure relevant du
dispositif de protection de l'enfance un
chiffre en augmentation ces dernières
années des manquements graves de la
prise en charge des enfants dans les
foyers ont suscité ces dernières années
la polémique en france
face au déferlement médiatique adrien
taquet le secrétaire d'état chargé de la
protection de l'enfance vient d'annoncer
un renforcement des contrôles
en outre des associations dénoncent les
placements abusifs sur la foi de
rapports de travailleurs sociaux
contestable à charge et qui ne tiendrait
pas compte de l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant
à tel point que le député liberté et
territoire jean lassalle a créé un
groupe de travail sur le sujet cet
ensemble de professionnels de la santé
avocats psychologues médecins
associations estiment que la parole des
experts et des enfants n'est pas
toujours écoutés et que de nombreux
petits sont arrachés sont toujours de
raison objective à leurs parents dans le
cadre de séparation conflictuelle mais
je dirais impressionné par le nombre de
personnes qui venaient nous voir en
disant côté on peut plus voir notre
enfant il nous a été enlevé
soit la naissance soit plus tard bien ne
l'a jamais ramené à part quelques petits
car que l'on peut-être plus réseau
nous n'avons pas pu avancer un peu comme
si ce sujet était tabou
nous avons contacté le département du
gard dont dépend l'aide sociale à
l'enfance qui gère le dossier de noah
ces services ne peuvent répondre à nos
questions car la justice est saisie
le 7 avril éric morel le procureur de la
république de nîmes a promis de
s'entretenir avec le juge des enfants et
de faire analyser le dossier par des
magistrats du parquet mais le temps
passe le tribunal de nîmes nous a
informés qu'il ne répondrait à aucune
question karim trappe laissera-t-elle sa
vie faute de pouvoir être entendu au
sujet de ses fils